[Music]
the year of our sword 2013 devolver
digital and developer flying wild hog
rebooted the seminal 1997 slash nasty
Shadow Warrior series to a skull
thumping spectacle of bullets blades and
blood demon blood then in 2016 Shadow
Warrior 2 up [ __ ] the bar for
first-person melee combat and maximum
next-level ninja [ __ ] and one of our
most successful games ever forever now
Shadow Warrior 3 set to vote the series
forward again by expanding its trademark
combat and piling on a [ __ ] ton of new
additions like brutal executions
thrilling annihilation and gorgeous
acrobatics making every battle a new
violent portrait to paint it is time
and then cover those cherry blossoms
with buckets of blood blood
ladies gentlemen folks your first look
at flying wild hog Magnum [ __ ]
opus Shadow Warrior
[Music]
roll it [ __ ] yeah howdy stranger ja
Frank where are you did you hear me
kaitlin's they're trying to break
through the tapes I'll track you down
[Music]
[Music]
oh I bet that had to hurt
[Music]
hey Ross
[Music]
[Music]
I'm home
[Music]
delicious absolutely pudding too